it's the news nobody wants to hear it's
a tragic development in the search for
22-year-old gabby petito she disappeared
during a road trip with her fiance
authorities say they have found a body
in northwestern wyoming and it's
believed to be gabby tito was last seen
nearly a month ago and her fiance brian
laundry returned home to florida without
her he has not been seen for nearly a
week after the body was found petito's
father shared this picture with the
words she touched the world tariqa
duncan is outside the laundry family
home in north port on florida's gulf
coast tariqa this was really i was so
sad to hear this last night good morning
to you
good morning i think everyone was
holding on to some hope that maybe they
would find gabby a lie but we're here in
front of brian laundry's home there's
been no activity here this morning and
even yesterday when we were here as the
fbi made that grim announcement but
right now as the sun starts to come up
the focus is trying to find brian
laundry his parents told police they
believe he's in a nearby 25 thousand
acre reserve police say they still want
to speak with him and hope that he could
provide some answers as to how gabby
potito died
remains were discovered
consistent with the description of
gabrielle gabby petito after more than a
week of searching the fbi now believes
it found what appears to be gabby
potito's body near grand teton national
park in wyoming the cause of death has
not been determined at this time gabby
pito never goes outside
petito disappeared while on a
cross-country trip with her fiance brian
laundry so
we are
right outside capitol reef right now
laundry is believed to have returned
home to florida september first without
her
investigators want to speak with him but
over the weekend his family told
authorities they haven't seen him since
september 14.
do you think they're telling the truth
i think at this point anything's on the
table josh taylor is the spokesperson
for the northport florida police
department he was back here in this
community for 10 days before she was
reported missing it's a lot of time for
somebody to kind of get their act
together we certainly think brian has
some explaining to do at one point more
than 50 agents were searching for him in
the nature reserve near the house where
he lived with potito cbs news spoke to
gabby petito's closest friend rose davis
who told us the couple had their issues
every relationship has the bumps and
everything like that i would never have
thought
this could happen through a series of
tick-tock videos and pictures davis
pleaded for any information about her
best friend and told us she thinks
laundry has to know something i wanted
to text him and just be like
please please give me something davis
says petito always had a way of putting
a smile on davis face she will do
everything to bring the light out in you
and if she can't she'll give you some of
hers
laundry's family attorney put out a
statement calling the news about gabby
potito heartbreaking and saying that
they are praying for the potato family
innate it's important to note uh that
josh taylor that pio that we spoke to
yesterday said he is confident that they
will find brian laundry
nate let's hope so uh jerica thank you
so much an unfortunate ending to a story
that we've been following we've all been
following that i hope they find him
sooner rather than later and just what
the police officer said to tariqa they
always know more than what they're
telling us always in a case like this it
raises a question for a lot of people
why they weren't following brian landry
since people had had a lot of suspicions
about him from the very beginning you
don't go on a trip and come back by
yourself and then refuse to answer and
last week they said we know where he is
yeah and then now they don't yeah even
though she was found i know the family
still wants more answers exactly